claire mauss copeaux et historienne
pendant des années elle est allée en
algérie recueillir la parole des femmes
qui ont vécu la guerre d'indépendance
très peu au taux dé briser le tabou des
violences sexuelles
ce sont les anciens soldats qui en ont
parlé à l'historienne photos à l'appui
un membre de l'armée française qui
dispose d'un bâton qui désigne le sexe
du prisonnier
[Musique]
humiliation des hommes mais aussi
exhibition des femmes avant de les
abuser
les viols pouvait avoir lieu partout
à l'intérieur des mechtas à l'extérieur
sur le terrain dans les cantonnements
des militaires dans les prisons dans les
gendarmeries les viols pouvait avoir
lieu partout et les viols pouvait avoir
lieu n'importe quand et de savoir que
c'est violent n'était jamais punis sauf
exception
les femmes algériennes font pourtant
tout pour échapper aux soldats quand il
approche du village elles se rassemblent
prennent leurs enfants contre elle
certaines se couvrent même de bouse de
vache pour dégoûter l'agresseur mais ces
techniques ne suffisent pas toujours
la femme
représenter l'algérie qui voulait son
indépendance c'est parce qu'elle ne se
soumet pas qu'ils sont la combattre en
algérie à s'ennuyer en algérie qu'ils
ont quitté la france qu'ils ont quitté
leur repère donc ils se vengent est ce
c'est plus facile de se venger sur une
femme que de se venger sur un homme
au début des années 2000 c'est cette
femme qui révèle la pratique des viols
pendant la guerre d'algérie
de retour au siège de la 10e division
parachutiste à alger louisette
ighilahriz raconte les sévices qu'il y a
subi en 1957
ça commençait par les gifles des coups
points et puis des grossièretés avec q
les nombreuses
beaucoup beaucoup pour moi puis après
monsieur a débordé à la limite j'aurais
préféré des tortures enfin j'aurais
préféré la jgr j'aurais préféré les
bidoire j'aurais préféré je ne sais pas
les coups les insultes et injures ni
crachats
et puis niveau grossier de la cgtg je
m'attendais à tout cela mais pas aux
vieux
un témoignage rare mais pas unique
d'autres combattante comme bayala noire
affirmant avoir subi le même sort
parfois aux mains de dizaines de soldats
à la fin de la guerre sur les hauteurs
d'alger henri pouillot 22 ans est nommé
secrétaire à la villa susini
s'ils pensent d'abord être tranquille il
découvre bientôt que le palais est un
centre de torture pour les hommes et un
enfer pour les femmes
il ya un certain nombre de femmes aiment
quand même qu'il n'a été arrêté que pour
satisfaire les besoins sexuels que des
militaires sur place la femme était
arrêté est passé dans la chambre et
c'était les gens vous y avait deux trois
militaires le plein
la plupart du temps elle était gelée par
chacun des militaires présents
en 2001 henri pouillot est retourné à
alger invité par les indépendantistes
aux algériens à cette occasion il a
rencontré louisette ighilahriz celle par
qui le scandale est arrivé
et ce qui l'a le plus surpris ce sont
les attaques dont elle a fait l'objet
dans son propre pays plusieurs projets
très très très violemment d'avoir
témoigné publiquement de deux d'avoir
d'avoir subi des viols cet aspect de
culpabilité des femmes que je suis très
très dur à encaisser pour les algériens
de cette époque parce que l on subit
junte est victime et est en plus
considéré comme coupable
honte et remords des anciens soldats en
france
censure des femmes ou trajets en algérie
la question des violences sexuelles
pendant le conflit reste bien camouflé
de part et d'autre de la méditerranée